this video is sponsored by crossrope
you know that the person with the lower
resting heart rate isn't always the
person who's going to have the better
aerobic fitness that's because many
different things can impact on our heart
rate for example if you have a higher
level of resting adrenaline then you're
actually going to have a slightly higher
heart rate even if your heart health is
really good this isn't always a bad
thing in fact some with a higher level
of resting adrenaline can actually begin
exercise quicker and with less of a
warm-up versus someone with a lower
level this just goes to show the
difficulty in monitoring measuring and
comparing aerobic fitness but one of the
most popular measurements used to
monitor cardiovascular fitness va2 Max
or maximal oxygen uptake is a measure of
the maximum amount of oxygen an
individual can use during intense
exercise in other words this is the
upper limit of your aerobic capacity and
it's very well correlated with overall
endurance and performance in fact we
might consider it to be the gold
standard to me it's always seemed
Madness to have someone who goes to the
gym and lifts a few weights and then
says that means they're definitely fit
and in great shape if you still can't
touch your toes then being able to lift
weights doesn't make you instantly fit
likewise if you get gassed out going up
the stairs then I don't think you can
really call yourself in great shape this
is why I think everybody should do at
least something to focus on and improve
their aerobic fitness and their
cardiovascular health this is going to
improve your longevity it's also going
to make you work out better because
you'll have better work capacity and
you'll get so tired and it's even going
to increase your energy and alertness
throughout the day so many people want
to find this magical Elixir that's going
to give them more energy make them feel
less tired but so few people consider
just doing cardio so whether you're
someone like me who's interested in
maximizing Human Performance and getting
the very most out of your training or
you just want to improve your General
Health and energy levels you're going to
find something useful by examining VO2
max
virtue Max is written as ml kg Min or
milliliters of oxygen consumed per
kilogram of body weight every minute
catchy anything around 50 to 60 would be
considered a good score with some
athletes having scores as high as 80 or
above an athlete's VO2 max is best
measured in a laboratory environment
using a mask or mouthpiece connected to
a metabolic cart this then monitors the
volume of oxygen inhaled and the amount
of carbon dioxide exhaled they'll then
be given an incremental exercise test
while levels are monitored the highest
oxygen consumption Valley recorded prior
to exhaustion is considered the va2 max
for those of you without high-tech lab
equipment sitting around your house
there are other options for example you
can use the Cooper test by running as
fast as possible for 12 minutes and then
using the following equation to
calculate a va2 Max score you should see
that on the screen now
many fitness trackers will also provide
a VO2 max estimate once they've
collected enough data while these scores
are not perfectly accurate they are
actually close enough to be considered
useful and as we'll see no method of
measuring VO2 max is perfect but with
training the aim is to improve VO2 max
over time as long as we have a
consistent measurement we can see those
improvements occur multiple adaptations
impact on a person's ability to utilize
oxygen for example cardiac output the
volume of blood pumped by the heart per
minute will of course impact on the
amount of blood delivered to the muscles
having more and more efficient
mitochondria is also beneficial as is
having a higher hemoglobin concentration
and a greater capillary density for
delivering the oxygen directly to the
working muscles there are many potential
avenues for effectively training to
enhance the A2 max if all you're doing
right now is jogging then you're leaving
a lot of potential gains on the table
for example good old high intensity
interval training has repeatedly been
shown to be effective for improving the
A2 Max even more effective though is a
hit or aerobic hit in this form of high
intensity interval training the
Intensive periods use aerobic exercise
that is to say you run or swim or jog
just below the anaerobic threshold the
point at which your body is no longer to
deliver oxygen to the muscles quickly
enough and lactate begins to build up in
the blood in response to the switch to
other Energy Systems and this makes
sense by staying within the Aerobic
System you ensure that the focus remains
on that system but you're pushing it to
the max triggering an adaptation
response and by using the interval
system you're able to accomplish more
volume have greater rest times etc for
those at home you can roughly
guesstimate the correct level of
exertion by using the torque test if
you're able to speak in short sentences
but unable to engage in full
conversation you are likely exerting
yourself a suitable amount this likely
occurs somewhere between 75 to 90
percent of Max heart rate ironically a
lot of people actually perform vanilla
hit incorrectly and are in fact already
unwittingly performing aerobic hit
that's because most people just don't
run fast enough during their hit
sessions to actually go into an
anaerobic State and with that said some
code coaches and athletes focus more on
the use of super maximal training and
other strategies that train just above
the anaerobic threshold an emerging
field of research is focusing on
individual differences and how different
training methods may work better for
different athletes based on their
genetics but as we've seen there are
many other interesting strategies we can
use for example altitude training by
living and or training at higher
elevations where oxygen is less readily
available athletes can force adaptations
such as increased hemoglobin but it's
not all that happens other factors such
as exercise efficiency and mitochondrial
function may also be impacted
inspiratory muscle training IMT also
sometimes known as respiratory muscle
training is also a valid option this
training uses exercises to Target the
diaphragm and other breathing muscles so
that you can bring in more oxygen and
pump it around faster during exertion
this may not only improve va2 Max during
exercise though but it could also be
effective at improving brain function
and alertness even at rest as more
oxygen is delivered to the brain and
muscles you can achieve this by using
something as simple as a straw in your
mouth and many people swear by it and
breath holding actually provides another
way to strengthen breathing muscles such
as the intercostals and diaphragm and
may even help to teach the body to
become more efficient in its use of
oxygen breath holding is a part of many
ancient Traditions but it's largely been
forgotten see my video on Aquaman
training for more on this but coming at
this from a completely different angle
it's also possible that Blood Flow
Restriction bfr might be useful for some
athletes here tournament cats are used
to restrict blood flow to the muscles
more specifically blood is able to enter
the working muscle but not as easily
exit this creates local hypoxia low
oxygen which can stimulate angiogenesis
the growth of nuclearies either way
what's interesting about these methods
is that they are local in nature this is
key to understand adaptations occur both
systemically and locally and so your VO2
max might actually be different for one
exercise modality than the other you
might have a great endurance for running
for example but average endurance for
swimming that's because you might have
built lots of blood supply to the legs
but not so much to the arms there will
be some crossover but the specialist in
that sport will perform best if like me
you're interested is in general
all-around performance then you may do
best to look at forms of aerobic
exercise that Target the full body a
great example is jump rope while you're
jumping over the Rope you're also
swinging the arms thereby creating
demand at both ends of the body and that
brings me to today's sponsor Crossroad
cross rope makes some of the best jump
ropes in the world in my opinion and I
have tried a lot this is thanks to the
superior spinach mechanics to make them
feel extremely smooth in the hand the
extreme durability accomplished with a
combination of Steel and a proprietary
coating and the easy interchangeability
of different ropes and more they don't
get tangled up all the time like other
ropes they're just far more enjoyable to
use I genuinely notice a huge difference
versus cheaper ropes there's even a
smart rope that will track your
performance over time and let you follow
along with guided workouts via the app
in real time
best of all crossrape also takes the
concept of getting a whole body workout
even further by providing a range of
weighted ropes the heavier of these
allow you to burn more calories and
really feel your shoulders and core
working during your regular sessions
combine this with some of the techniques
we've discussed here and you can
significantly elevate your VO2 max in no
time best of all crossrope offers a
60-day no questions asked trial program
so if you don't get on with it you can
just send it back and as an added bonus
Buy near viewers can use code bioneer to
get 15 off their order thanks again to
Crossroad for sponsoring this video and
now on with the show another option of
course would be to train with multiple
kinds of aerobic activity by combining
trail running with swimming or boxing
with skipping for example your entire
system would be better adapted for
various endurance tasks and you never
know what life's going to throw at you
this is all before we consider exercise
economy as you get better at your chosen
activity you'll be able to perform it
more efficiently and with less wasted
energy while this won't technically
directly impact your va2 max it will
impact on how fast you can move and for
how long before the va2 max is reached
these factors explain why I can easily
run 10K in under an hour without giving
it much thought but get gassed out
almost immediately during sparring I'm
simply not as adapted to that activity
and it's reflected in my performance and
this may be why measures such as FTP or
functional threshold power aka the
maximum wattage a person could produce
for an hour referred by cyclists
unfortunately there's no easy way to
obtain such a measurement for many other
sports
point is specificity matters here both
in training and in measurement but if we
take a multi-faceted approach to
training our endurance one that trains
the heart respiratory muscles and
working muscles themselves and if we
train across different disciplines with
multiple modalities we should see some
impressive results a cross the board
so let me know what you guys think do
you guys actively Monitor and train your
VO2 max is aerobic fitness important to
you in general let me know what your
methods are in the comments down below
if you're interested in training that
goes beyond just strength and Aesthetics
but also looks at things like Mobility
agility cardio Fitness and more then you
might like my ebook and training program
super functional training 2.0 the
protein performance system this is for
those people that want all around
Fitness and who don't want to have to
choose just one modality it comes with
an 80 plus page ebook and over two hours
of training and you'll find a link to
that in the description down below
either way guys thank you so much for
watching this one and I'll see you next
time
bye for now